nicola sturgeon sonríe el partido de la
ministra principal de escocia venció en
las elecciones legislativas celebradas
el jueves y cuyos resultados de este
sábado le dan la victoria a los
independentistas es el cuarto mandato
consecutivo para la formación
destrucción que esperaba conseguir una
mayoría absoluta sin embargo el partido
nacional escocés se quedó a un escaño de
ese logro y necesitará el apoyo de los
verdes para seguir impulsando un nuevo
referendo soberanista
de ninguna manera se puede describir
este referendo solo como una petición
mía o del partido nacional escocés es un
compromiso hecho al pueblo por una clara
mayoría de los parlamentarios que han
sido elegidos los conservadores del
primer ministro británico boris johnson
se quedaron con 31 diputados lejos de
los 72 que acumulan los independentistas
y los verdes en un hemiciclo de 129
diputados al respecto boris johnson se
ofreció al diálogo me gustaría invitar
la que sea una a mí a los colegas del
gobierno del reino unido- y a otros en
una cumbre para discutir nuestro desafío
los compartidos y ver cómo podemos
trabajar juntos en los meses y años
venideros para superarlos
londres se apoye en el referendo de 2014
en donde el rechazo a la independencia
venció por el 55% de los votos aseguran
que esa fue una votación que se hace una
vez por generación